i had a question recently that i wanted
to answer
and this was the question will a liver
cleanse
help my cirrhosis or will it help my
fatty liver
my ammonia is high and
is the liver cleanse gonna help me so
let's just talk about that
now the first thing you should know
about cirrhosis it's an advanced
situation in fact your risk for cancer
goes way up
uh 80 percent of people with liver
cancer
have some type of cirrhosis going on
because cancer tends to grow in damaged
tissue
and as you damage the liver certain
things don't work anymore there's an
enzyme called arginase
this is an enzyme that is involved
in something called the urea cycle see
when you break down protein into amino
acids
the extra amount of it uh has to go
through
as waste nitrogen waste so arginase
is necessary in making sure that happens
making sure that there's a complete
breakdown
so it can exit the body without any
toxicity
if there's not enough arginase in the
liver we get an incomplete
breakdown of arginine this is the amino
acid
then we get higher amounts of ammonia
in the blood which can travel up to the
brain
and that can create a lot of different
side effects like
coma dementia
all sorts of brain problems seizures
tremors
so ammonia is very very toxic and too
much ammonia that builds up into the
brain or the tissues
really is there because there's not
enough this enzyme because there's
damage
in the liver so the body cannot go
through its normal
urea cycle and um clean up this extra
amount of protein going on
now just as a side note when i'm talking
about damage to the liver
i'm not just talking about cirrhosis
which kind of leaves your
liver cells dysfunctional it can also be
a severely inflamed liver so you can
have hepatitis
which leaves your liver dysfunctional
you can have a fatty liver which
stops the function or scar tissue
and sometimes the fat in the liver
creates inflammation that develops in
the scar
sometimes inflammation in the liver
leads to insulin resistance
which then creates more fat in the liver
then you have a situation we have
inflammation in the liver
which directly turns into scar tissue
that's cirrhosis now the big question is
will a liver cleanse
help this well the problem is your liver
is not dysfunctional because there's
toxins in it necessarily this is a
progressive
chronic condition that has developed
over years
that a liver cleanse probably is not
going to even touch
it may instead stir up a hornet's nest
it may
make your symptoms worse it could
actually release
certain bacteria certain chemicals that
are lodged in your fat cells and then
actually recirculate through your blood
end up in your thyroid and create all
sorts of problems so
i don't recommend a liver cleanse what i
do recommend
is this number one i know this might
shock you
but i'm going to recommend keto why
because
keto is a much cleaner fuel it creates
less inflammation than carbs
it's very beneficial to your liver and
it can
help you in reducing a fatty liver
number two fasting what is that good for
inflammation it'll help you drop
inflammation it'll give your
liver a chance to heal and that's what
we're trying to minimize is the
inflammation here to allow it to heal
so these two are essential you want to
make sure that you do not consume too
much protein
three ounces per meal would be perfect
why because
the problem is that we have an
incomplete protein breakdown
so why would we want to add more protein
to your liver it's already damaged you
don't have enough of this enzyme
next thing to do is to take a product
that has l-arginine
and manganese manganese is a good
trace mineral to help detoxify you
and the amino acid which is a
non-essential one l-arginine as a
supplement it's usually in a powder you
can get it in capsules
can help reduce ammonia if there's not
enough arginase there's not going to be
enough arginine
so manganese is a precursor or a
building block for arginase and it can
help to
increase the ability to detoxify the
body number five we want to
increase vegetables
and celery that gives us chlorophyll
and other natural phytochemicals to help
the liver function a lot better
so instead of a detox cleanse
the best way to clean the liver is
through the natural phytonutrients that
comes from
food and chlorophyll will help as well
the phytonutrients in plants
are enzymes that help different phases
of detoxification
and without side effects so
these are very very important in the
detoxification
number six tocatrinals this is a type of
vitamin e
that comes in handy and it's a very
powerful antioxidant in fact the
tocotrienols
version of vitamin e is 50 times
stronger than the tocopherols
and it can greatly and help inhibit
inflammation
so if you have the start of cirrhosis or
you have cirrhosis in the liver which is
scar tissue vitamin e is going to help
in this form talk adrenals
but if you think about it vitamin e is
good for scars right
helps break down scar tissue well why
can't it work
for scar tissue on the inside of the
body as well
very important and number seven
probiotics
there's some great research on
probiotics that can help decrease
ammonia in the body as well i put a link
down below
but this is the protocol that i would
recommend uh
way better than a liver cleanse by
itself thanks for watching
before you go if you have a question
about a product or you're new to keto
and you want to know how to begin keto
or you're on
keto and you need a debug because it's
not going as smooth
i have a keto consultant standing by to
help you
this is just for the people in the us
hopefully in the future we'll be able to
answer everyone's call
but i put the number down below so you
can call
and get some help